-Our first guest tonight
is an Academy Award-nominated
actor you know him for his work
in "Spotlight" and "Birdman"
as well as iconic films such as
"Batman" and "Beetlejuice."
Don't sleep on "Multiplicity"
or "The Paper."
I'm gonna throw
a couple more in there.
He stars in "Worth,"
which begins streaming
on Netflix September 3rd.
Let's take a look.
-I've got -- what? --
1,100 families on board
and 6,000 more to go.
-Uh-huh, yeah.
-Well, I just want you to know
that I know
the fund's not perfect.
There are people
who just don't fit
within the rules that we wrote.
I know that.
I honestly
don't know what to do.
-Please welcome back to the show
our friend Michael Keaton.
How are you, Michael?
-I'm good, man.
Nice to see you.
-Yeah, it's nice
to see you, too.
You know,
I wish it wasn't on Zoom.
-Well, you know, I know.
Hold on a sec.
I'm getting a call.
-Getting a call?
-No.
I'm texting Jimmy Fallon.
-Oh, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-That's cool.
Yeah, I'm glad -- I'm glad
you guys get a long.
-Anyways, sorry.
-'Cause, you know,
I would have thought --
and one thing if, like,
you don't leave Montana,
I get it.
But last week, look at you two.
Thick as thieves.
-Yeah.
-Laughing it up.
Look how happy he is.
-I know.
[ Laughter ]
-No one's ever reacted like that
to a Zoom interview.
[ Laughter ]
-That's true.
That's true.
Yeah.
Give me a minute.
I miss --
It was only a week ago, I guess.
Let me reminisce a little bit.
I missed it so much.
[ Laughter ]
-It is great to see you.
-That's true, though.
That's true, though.
That's very funny.
No, you're right.
People don't --
You can't do that on a Zoom.
There's so much you can't do.
Honestly,
I did want to be there.
It was my fault.
I kind of screwed up.
I thought only --
We could only do this via Zoom.
Plus, I have to tell you,
they give me pie when I'm there.
-At the Fallon show?
At "The Tonight Show"?
-Yeah.
Yeah.
-Is that all it takes?
[ Laughter ]
-Well, I like pie, and --
I don't know.
It's just
never been offered to me.
You guys have had --
-You think if we didn't
know that
we wouldn't get you a pie?
-I don't know.
-You're Michael Keaton.
-I didn't even ask.
They just kind of said,
"Hey, Mike, you like some pie?"
[ Laughter ]
-I said, "[Bleep] yeah.
I love some pie."
I'm a pie man
more than a cake man.
I'll eat cake,
but pie is my preference.
Anyway, I'm sorry.
[ Laughter ]
Sorry it didn't work out.
-No, I get it.
And, by the way, my feelings --
It was only that you were here
that I -- you know, I was like,
"Oh, he comes here,"
because you were in Montana.
-Yeah.
-I do -- I have enjoyed that
our Zooms during this time,
I'm getting to see other corners
of your beautiful home there.
-Yeah.
-But you are like --
You're an actual horseman.
Is that the right way --
You, like,
will ride horses out there?
-Yeah, yeah. No, no -- horseman
is a good way to put it.
Yeah, I do.
I do.
I'm, you know --
If I would open the window,
I would look at them now.
But what I was thinking about
was maybe you might want
to think about it is,
when we're done,
just get somebody to photograph
you throwing your head back,
laughing, like a --
Just insert it --
-Right, okay.
-You know, make it look like --
[ Laughter ]
Yes!
That's perfect!
Perfect, perfect, perfect.
-Now, I would imagine
you take it seriously --
-I am here,
and I do ride quite a bit.
I haven't had much time
because, you know --
We'll talk about this project
I'm involved with, "Worth."
So I've been, you know,
talking about that a lot.
But, one of --
speaking of my horses, actually,
I'm not a --
Not a giant consumer,
you know, of things.
I don't -- I actually don't
need a lot of stuff,
which is fortunate,
so then I don't have to go out
and buy a lot of stuff.
But one of the things I did
recently, speaking of horses,
was I kept telling myself,
"Someday, I'm going to
treat myself --"
which, you know,
is kind of difficult
for me to do.
"But I want to treat myself
to something,"
and I thought, "Yeah.
You know what I'm gonna do?
Instead of all these used,
really nice good saddles I have
that, you know, I bought
secondhand or a friend of mine
gave me one as a gift,
I'm gonna treat myself
to a handmade saddle,"
which is an art form,
to have a handmade saddle.
So, I contacted this guy
whose last name is Cooper.
He's a very good saddle maker.
Out of Texas,
moved to California.
He started to work on my saddle.
And that takes --
You know, that's a process.
So, we started.
I went up to his shop,
and I said,
"Yeah, let's get started."
Then we would e-mail.
We would e-mail
one another back and forth.
And it gets
in the minutia, you know?
It gets pretty esoteric
unless you know
what you're talking about.
So we'd go back and forth.
I'd go, "Hey, man.
You know,
in terms of the saddle horn,
you know what I think?
I think we need a 3/4
instead of a half inch,"
blah, blah, blah.
"The skirt should be like this.
I don't want
a full oxbow stirrup.
Maybe --"
And we're going back and forth.
And he'd respond, and then
there would be these gaps,
and I wouldn't hear from him,
and I'd go,
"Hey. How you doing?
Just checking in."
You know, "We were talking about
the engraving
down on the bottom.
Keep it simple."
"Yeah, okay. Ha, ha!"
Exclamation point, right?
And I'm going,
"All right, you know.
You know, he's enjoying this."
Then I wouldn't
hear from him for a while.
And I'd go, "Hey,
just checking in," you know?
"What do you think about
the blah, blah, blah."
And he'd go "Sure."
So I'm like, "Okay, whatever."
I'd go, "Whatever?"
[ Laughter ]
Right?
That's my boy, Cash Cooper.
And I'd go, "Hey, I haven't
heard from you in a while."
"Yeah,"
and then there'd be nothing.
And then, one day,
I e-mailed him something to --
"Let's wrap this up,"
because admittedly,
I was taking a long time.
And then, I hear -- he e-mails
me back, "Who is this?"
I go, "'Who is this?'
What are you talking about,
'Who is this?'"
I had been mistakenly e-mailing
Bradley Cooper.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah.
The whole time --
And he's on the other end going,
"What the [bleep]
is he even talking --
I don't even know
what this means."
And then he --
I thought it was hysterical.
And I e-mailed him back,
and I go, "Oh, man,
that is so funny,"
blah, blah, blah.
And he goes, "Yeah, I was kind
of rolling along with it,
but I didn't know
what I was supposed to say."
And he said, "I thought it was
really a great gag,
but I ran out --
I kind of ran out, you know,
because you were getting
really specific..."
[ Laughter ]
"...about stuff."
-That's fantastic!
I love that.
You did put a unfair pressure
on him that he's like,
"Okay. We're doing a bit.
I don't understand it."
[ Laughter ]
-Right, exactly.
Yeah.
It's just like, "You know..."
-I do want
to talk about the movie.
We'll be right back with more
from Michael Keaton.